[Música]
economía en directo américa de france24
àngel hablando nuevamente en el estudio
dan y vamos a hablar de lo que pasa
económicamente con esta guerra porque en
medio de las duras sanciones ahora el
temor es que rusia no pague lo que debe
porque raúl el país se enfrenta a un
vencimiento clave esta semana
concretamente el miércoles cuando debe
pagar intereses por 117 millones de
dólares sobre dos bonos de deuda pública
pero los pagos deben hacerse en dólares
y recordemos que las sanciones de
occidente pues han limitado el acceso
justamente a sus reservas
internacionales el ministro de finanzas
ruso reveló que esto afecta casi a la
mitad de las reservas extranjeras pero
aseguró que los pagos de deuda externa
se harían en rublos y también acusa a
occidente de organizar lo que llamó una
quiebra artificial los que no consideran
esto mismo son los del fondo monetario
internacional
in terms of servicing data obligations
en términos del servicio de las
obligaciones de la deuda puedo decir que
ya no pensamos en el incumplimiento de
pago de rusia como un evento improbable
rusia tiene el dinero para pagar su
deuda pero no puede acceder a él
y dejar lo que más me preocupa es que
haya consecuencias que vayan más allá de
ucrania y rusia yo creé en raya y
seguimos en europa a daniela porque los
consumidores se apresuran a comprar
pastillas para protegerse de una posible
radiación esto de cara a una posible
digamos y se escala mucho el conflicto
de una guerra nuclear que estamos lejos
pero pues la gente tiene miedo claro en
esto es comprensible no en estos casos
la red es lo que llaman compras de
pánico raúl no solamente tan crean sus
carros lo que también se abastecen de
estos productos y es que no se ha
desencadenado en europa central una
especie de ansiedad entre quienes temen
que pueda convertirse esta guerra en una
guerra nuclear con la planta de
chernóbil en
ahora controlada por las fuerzas rusas y
también después del bombardeo vas a
morir ya que es la central nuclear más
grande de europa pues muchos
consumidores se han apresurado a comprar
yodo y yoduro de potasio o también
conocido como jordina porque creen que
así pueden protegerse de la radiación y
cómo se protegen danny qué propiedades
tiene este producto porque mire raúl el
yodo se toma en pastillas o en jarabe y
se considera una forma de proteger al
organismo contra afecciones como el
cáncer de tiroides esto en caso de una
exposición a la radioactividad en 2011
de hecho las autoridades japonesas
recomendaron su uso en los alrededores
de la central nuclear de fukushima
después del accidente que hubo en esta
planta pero esta vez las autoridades
sanitarias dicen que no ayudaría mucho
en caso de una guerra nuclear de todas
maneras no es lo mismo una guerra que un
accidente según la agencia bloomberg un
frasco de 180 pastillas de yodo de
potasio en europa ahora cuesta casi 70
dólares en amazon esto es más del doble
de lo que costaba a comienzos de año y
los que también pudieron haber entrado
en pánico son los rusos porque ya no
tienen instagram claro y es que casi
todas las redes se han ido de este país
bien sea o porque el gobierno las ha
bloqueado o también porque se unen al
boicot occidental contra el kremlin por
esta invasión a ucrania el turno de este
lunes fue para instagram que es de
propiedad de meta del mismo dueño de
facebook los rusos no pudieron acceder a
sus cuentas después de que el viernes la
duma que es el legislativo de rusia
acusar al gigante tecnológico de
permitir a sus usuarios llamar a la
violencia contra sus tropas
danny y hablemos entonces de los canales
estatales rusos que dejaron de funcionar
en youtube esto alrededor del mundo
claro que así pues esta empresa
propiedad de google bloqueó los canales
de medios oficialistas rusos que reciben
fondos del gobierno nosotros hicimos el
ejercicio raúl e intentamos acceder a la
página oficial de youtube de 'russia
today' y apareció un aviso de no
disponible como lo ven ustedes en sus
pantallas en un comunicado el portavoz
de youtube explicó que las normas
internas de este portal prohíben los
contenidos que nieguen minimicen o
trivialicen los efectos violentos
documentados en este caso se estaba
refiriendo obviamente a la guerra en un
kart y ahora si dan y ante todo esto
cómo están los mercados pues hubo una
sesión mixta en asia pero el índice de
hang seng de hong kong se hundió un 5
por ciento después de que se ordenara el
cierre de la ciudad vecina de shenzhen
para combatir el peor brote de kobe 19
en china en dos años como ya lo informa
vamos las acciones en europa suben a
media marcha en con un ojo puesto en los
diálogos entre rusia y ucrania y el otro
puesto en la reunión de la reserva
federal de martes y miércoles y la cifra
el día que nos tiene hoy la cifra del
día del 22 por ciento que subió en
promedio la gasolina en eeuu en apenas
dos semanas ahora están un récord de 443
dólares por galón debido a los altos
precios del petróleo aunque está bajando
un 5% el día de hoy a medida que se van
normalizando rom anunciando las cosas si
así se puede así están y muchísimas
gracias entonces por toda la información
nos vemos mañana con más economía vamos
directo hasta parís